okay so i've been wanting to make a
video about this game for a while
because it's one of my favorite
anti-london
games of all time and i remember when i
first discovered this game
i was just in awe very much like
discovering an ancient form of art
where i just wanted to stare at it and
appreciate its beauty
and for anyone who despises a london i
hope this game will bring you some joy
and some happiness in life
this is a reminder do the audible
sponsorship
oh that's right this video is sponsored
by audible
do the audible sponsorship okay let's do
the audible sponsorship
audible sponsorship time so i'll start
by saying
that i turned down almost all
sponsorship and brand deal requests
but when the opportunity came to work
with audible
it was pretty much a no-brainer i'm a
huge fan of their platform
and i've been an audible member for the
last several years
and i'll give a quick preview to my
audible library
i'm into a lot of the the
self-improvement kind of business
genre audiobooks and one book that i
can't recommend
enough is the art of learning by josh
waitskin
it talks about his experience not only
as a chess player
but a world-class competitor in martial
arts
and he really dissects the science
behind learning
and it's a type of book i think every
chess player
should read because it kind of gives you
a big picture
understanding of how to go from beginner
to mastery not only in chess but really
any field in life
so if you want to get this book for free
you can use a link
audible.com i am rosen or text i am
rosen to 500 500
and uh and i hope this brings you as
much value as it brought me
so anyway thanks again to audible for
sponsoring this video
and let's get back to some chess uh this
game was played between two grand
masters
uh mom chill nikolov playing black and
vladimir pekkov
playing white and as we're gonna see
the white player got pretty crushed as
if
he was an amateur and uh that's one of
the beautiful things about this game
is a play for black flowed very nicely
and it seemed like white really didn't
have a chance and it wasn't clear where
white actually
went wrong in this game so opening
started
as you guessed it a london opening
and black plays c5 now actually i
checked this position
on the leachat database and the most
played move here is e6
which is another variation but it's not
a move i recommend
because it immediately blocks in black's
lightsword bishop
and very often you want to be flexible
because there's cases
where the bishop develops before you
play
pawn e6 so when black plays c5 this is
going for
kind of a more reversed queen's gambit
setup
where the knight develops behind the
pawn but not only that but black frees
open
this avenue for the queen to come to b6
and potentially attack the undefended
pawn on b2
and it's very common in the london for
the pawn on b2 just to be a weak point
in white's position
because the bishop has committed itself
so early and is no longer
on c1 so the game progresses some very
natural moves
from both sides black plays bishop f5
and after knight f3 we see black be kind
of the first player
to make a really media threat
attacking the pawn on b2 and the
combination of the queen
on b6 and the bishop on f5 is quite nice
because the bishop controls c2 and
b1 so white doesn't have moves like rook
b1
or queen c2 to effectively defend the
b-pawn
so the most natural move here which was
played in the game is queen b3
offering a queen trade and now we reach
kind of the stare down situation
where black doesn't necessarily want to
take on
b3 because that would only strengthen
white structure
and white would then have the half of an
a file
black really wants to make it so white
trades here
and then black can get the half of an a
file for himself
and with the next move pawn c4 this is
exactly what happens
um white is pretty much forced to take
on b6 a move like queen a3
is just terrible for white because e5
would hit the queen
and be winning the bishop so
queens got traded and now i think a lot
of players if they look to this position
for the first time
they would maybe think it's it's dry
like both bishops develop there's some
symmetry
um but from a higher level standpoint
this is actually really pleasant
to play for black it's already slightly
preferable for black
not only because black has the half of
an a file
more potential pressure on the queen
side but also has a space advantage with
the pawn advanced on c4 and potential
later to play b5 b4
so white plays a3 trying to undermine
the power of the rook
pawn b5 there are cases where black
wants to play pawn b4
making use of this pin so white just
moves a rook to c1
and now black plays kind of a slightly
mysterious move but very common move for
this position
pawn h6 and the reason to play pawn h6
before pawn e6
is there's cases where knight h4 could
be annoying
and because the lightsword bishop is one
of black's best pieces here
really nicely pierces through the
position you don't want to trade it off
for this knight
so the reason for black playing h6 is
just to create a nice kind of pocket
so if ever knight h4 the bishop can
safely
hide on h7 where it still controls a
really nice
long diagonal so play continues from
here
pawn h3 like kind of using the same idea
to preserve the dark sword bishop
e6 and now bishop e2
now i'm going to go ahead and hide the
notation because i don't want to
spoil what's about to happen next
and i'll start by saying that i think
most players here
would just kind of play automatically
like they'd be inclined to complete
the opening principles and just develop
with bishop e7
and castle and go into the middle game
but this is already a case
where black can start formulating a
more clear plan and the problem with
bishop e-7 and castling there's really
no clear like long-term plan
and this is a case where if black finds
the right
positional plan it can cause massive
massive
problems for lights as we're gonna see
in this game
so i'm gonna give this as an exercise to
everyone watching
this is black to move and feel free to
pause the video take your time and then
then we'll discuss okay so before i
reveal the move
i do want to explain what the key
weakness is in white's position
because if you don't identify the key
weakness it's very unlikely you'll find
the clear plan for black and the
weakness still turns out to be this pawn
in b2 even though it's not
easy to attack it's also not easy to
defend
and all black needs to do is get one
attacker against the pawn
now if we think a bit creatively and and
try and think okay how can we
potentially attack the pawn
we can imagine a knight coming to a4
would would be very strong and now if we
think backwards how do we add a knight
to a4
well we can get there via b6 how do we
get to beat b6 via d7
and then hopefully this will lead you to
finding
the key move knight to d7 and this is
the first step
in a three
move maneuver to
try and destroy white's queen sign and
even though this looks slow
it is neglecting the kingside
development for black
it's not easy for white to deal with and
we're going to see how quickly
white's position will crumble because
of this potential plan so in the game
like played pawn g4
trying to create some distraction black
very simply moves back to h7
and now bishop to d1 is a very typical
move for white
trying to offer the trade of
light-squared bishops
and imagine if the bishops do get traded
then a rook can come
and more effectively help defend the
pawn
black continues knight b6 bishop c2
and now we have a trade takes and takes
and this leads us to another key
position because it looks like white
should solve the problem
of uh of the pawn not being defended now
the rook
happily defends upon if you play knight
a4
okay then light looks pretty but it's
not doing anything these pawns are super
solid
and black needs to find another way to
make progress
in this position and this brings us to
the second
kind of exercise of the game this is
black to move
find the the really really nice
i don't know whether to call this a
positional move or a tactical move
but find the brilliant move that black
played
to completely devastate white so if you
don't see it feel free to pause the
video
and take your time okay so the move
requires
thinking a bit creatively and
also not rejecting anything too soon
when we look at this position we might
think that the b4 square
is off limits because white has two
pawns
very well controlling b4 but we can
still put something on b4
and make it work and the key move is
pawn b4
absolutely brilliant move and the thing
to realize here
is this a pawn it's no longer pinned to
the rook but it's pinned to the a1
square
if white ever takes rook a1 wins
material
because of the background skewer there's
no effective way to block
if you king e2 it's probably one of the
saddest king e2s
then you would lose a rook so
after b4 white is under pressure
the pawn on a3 is attacked and really
what black is trying to do is undermine
the queen side and make it so there
there's weaknesses that can't be
defended
uh what white played in the game was
just castling
now we should note if white takes on b4
black has a really really nice response
knight takes b4
and again if the a pawn takes this is
winning material for black even though
you just lost a knight
you're going to win uh win the rook and
be up at least
exchange another thing to mention is
when the knight comes to b4 attacking
the rook
we are also aiming to go into
d3 so if rook moves back we get
we get a very nice kind of quadruple
fork
of course we're just interested in
winning the rook knox move
and if rook to c3 again knight d3
this time we're interested in winning
the pawn which will probably result in
winning both
of the queen side pawns with just a
crushing position
so in this game after
pawn b4 white castled
and here black has a choice because you
can win a pawn
by taking on a3 and after
takes either take with bishop or rook
but
black didn't go for this variation
because when you win the pawn
white immediately gets counter play
along the b
file and you always have to be careful
when you win material
bother the possibilities of counter play
from the opponent
and in this case it's a little bit
uncomfortable because your knight's not
defended the pawn's not defended
and uh white white kind of can treat
this as a gambit situation
to get some annoying play so rather than
taking the pawn
on a3 black played a really surprising
move here
is pawn b3 forcing rook one
and i remember when i first saw this
game i was shocked that
black would play pawn b3 even though
okay black is winning connect five for
the memes
uh the the position is now completely
locked down
on the queen side and it seems as if
black's not going to be able to make any
more progress
uh what was played in the game knight a4
was met with rook b1
it seems like white just has everything
defended
so how in the world do you break through
but as we're going to see what comes
next
justifies black's whole play
leading up until this point because
after rook b1
black very happily goes ahead
and plays bishop takes a3 sacks a full
bishop
for the destruction of white's queenside
pawn structure
and there are cases where trading
a minor piece for some pawns is not so
good
but in this case it's completely
justified
because black is not only winning some
of these key pawns black is getting
two very dangerous connected past pawns
the a pawn is going to fall there's fork
potential
on e2 so a move like rook c1 would just
lose material
and the rest of the game was completely
one-sided from here
and white really never had any hope
for uh for surviving so if we go forward
rook b2
the knight went in traded itself off for
the bishop
and then black finally wins upon an e3
and despite white having extra knights
it's only so
so useful in the position and really the
pawns are going to be the ones
overpowering everything here
so rook c1 rook a2 is a nice move
if uh if the rooks get traded then the
pawn is always
just lingering on the second ring
waiting to queen
rook a1 would be met with knight 2 b4
and then
the king and rook will will come into
play not to mention the pawn
could potentially come all the way up to
b3 and then black would win connect 6.
so rather than taking the rook white
played rook b to b1
black played knight a5 we're going to
play through the next several moves
pawn b5 f5 and now black
black castled in this position wasn't
necessary kind of castling
uh in in the end game but the whole
point is to bring
the other rook in to help support the
advance
of the pawns white goes for 95
pawn b4 knight e3 and now b2
and when you have so many pawns like
this so deep
into the opponent's position you can be
pretty sure that the game is not going
to last too much longer
rookie one played pawn c3 creating this
nice sort of chain
knight d7 rook c8 you do have to give
credit to
the white player trying to create some
complications here
but after rook c6 uh knight takes d5 was
kind of a last desperate attempt and now
the icing of the cake
black decided to sack even more material
not even accepting the the sacrifice on
d5
but sacking the exchange on b6
to get the pawn to c2 and after king f3
knight b3 white threw in the towel here
and resigned
given that c1 promotes the queen is
coming
or knight d2 just too many problems that
white did not want to
suffer further from here so anyway
this was uh this is just a beautiful
game i really enjoyed how the play
blowed very smoothly uh from the initial
opening
black played kind of this this nice sort
of anti-london setup with the early
queen b6 and bishop f5
and got kind of this this nice middle
game
bind and then found the really
nice positional maneuver to to create
initial problems on the queen side
and then went for the very aesthetic
pawn push to b4
and then the peace sacrifice to destroy
white
so again for people that maybe
want some inspiration of how to take
down
the london opening i hope i hope this is
just one game you can add to your
toolbox
of of ways to fight against the london
and yeah if you have any questions leave
your comments below and i look forward
to seeing you
in the next video